he's Adam Sandler actor comedian and got
a new Netflix special 100% fresh is the
name of it it's great and Sandman that
that special is available starting today
on Netflix and Adam Sandler joining us
how are you saying man Daniel how are
you good morning I'm in New York City I
love you it's fun to be here
what are you working I'm doing a movie
the safty brothers you know who they are
I hear they're really popular really
important they're important with the
with the film community yeah now I'm a
part I'm a part of it now is this
another guy they know their sports by
the way they love you they love dance
packet but is this a film because you're
normally in movies yeah this is a film
that shooting it on film
they have to change the max every 20
minutes it's not like the Sandman movie
we could keep it rolling and you have a
social hour in the middle of it take
these guys mean business and then the
Sandman's following suit I got to do
what I got to do what's the name of the
movie um uncut gems and it's and I'm
wearing a costume and every time I'm in
it right now and I'll tell ya this cos
is pretty good less the less recognition
for the Sandman on the streets the last
people saying yo Sandman to me what do
they say merica what do they say to you
yeah well since this morning cuz the
Netflix special came out I've been
hearing people who do recognise me
thanks for the life-changer saying man I
couldn't I can't believe what you've
done for me and my whole family oh wow
that feels good okay what about Danny
what about my shirt is a special how
beautiful it looks
you wore a Dan Patrick show shirt that
has all of our names on it and I thought
it was great and absolutely it was
emotional for us we were very very proud
when we when we saw that so thank you we
appreciate you with product placement oh
great
it felt great it felt more comfortable
than the other shirts there did you
notice I dressed a little better in the
special
well you did and I was surprised you
weren't you couldn't have gone worse
so I know it was funny I was doing it
and I like I think I was shooting every
show I did and every time we watched
playback I wasn't wearing makeup and I
wasn't wearing good clothes and I would
show my wife I'd be like this is good
this shows good this crowd she's like
you look horrible you look disgusting I
think well yeah I didn't wear any makeup
she's like just put some makeup on
everyone else does so then the last
eight shows or something I wore a little
bit of something so I did sweat and then
I and then I had a nice lady run around
a Bobby some clothes that fit me for a
bit in there so there's a lot of songs
in this Netflix special it's called a
hundred percent fresh and you know I
love when you sing your songs but is it
is it reasonable to expect a newer
version of the Hanukkah song no I didn't
do any Hanukkah song because I don't I
haven't had time to write to do I I'm
waiting for fritzy to hand me that one
oh no you don't want that okay oh no but
ya know I'm still I'm still gonna get
you to do the Hanukkah song one time
when you're on the show when I'm coming
live I have to do it even if it's an old
one but I don't I don't have a I don't
have a new one yet man I just I did this
special is all new material all new
songs and then the only thing you bring
up to me fritzy asked me if I would
bring up the back row asked if I would
bring up if there was a new Hanukkah
song so you know you know I did I did I
thought the production I thought the way
it was shot I love the songs I I thought
that that was it was a it was a hundred
percent fresh is what it was Sammy it
was really well done a little cameo with
Rob Schneider so you
she got the playa and that will shot
that in Newark and he was flying and
work and I didn't get hurt and I was
good
when's the last time you dealt with a
tough crowd Oh III you know what's funny
for one of the shows I I came on at The
Improv in in Los Angeles and to look in
the little room there they have a little
group that's awesome
and I loved it there I was practicing my
material there a lot and so I said to be
grill who was the director let's shoot a
night there at the lab and I went there
and when I and I kept saying keep the
keep it dark though though make it look
like a whole camera crews here because I
just wanted to be see set but I just
dropped by and do stuff and the crowd
doesn't feel self-conscious above all so
then I can't stay go Adam Sandler and I
was upstairs and I walked downstairs and
I see it's really too bright and I walk
there and I was looking at the crowd and
I instead of saying hello to the crowd I
snapped for a second about if he liked
the room and and then I got I want to do
my acting it was it was about an hour 20
minutes of people hated me because I
snapped up so you lost the crowd right
away oh they were looking at me like wow
[Laughter]
I thought you're up there with like
Sandra Bullock America's Sweethearts and
that they don't people love you Sandman
I bet I bet about I'm batting 950 but
the 50 is pretty rough this and there
goes three hard for the crowd did not
like it no it's just with my anger issue
you got you go into the Lakers games
when you get done with your shooting I'm
going to you know I watch the first half
last night I had to go to sleep but it
was it's fun to watch him huh it's just
now I know
they lost in OT last night but I did
it's it's just fun it's fun to see a
LeBron and the Youngs appear together
the coos kid was hitting every shot last
night that was fun
buddy are you still a Knicks fan or is
that gone yeah I'm all Knicks all mix
but I have to wait wait I'll continue to
wait for something great and I care them
on every game I then part of me is like
just get in last place so we can get it
to tick but actually you know you don't
want it you don't want to not get a win
this year right no how if I had to guess
no so so you want them to lose a lot of
games too except when you're there I
can't it's funny I wanted to lose just a
draft pick but when I'm watch I can't
help but Luke Luke oh boy this stupid
man he's Adam Sandler his Netflix
special was 100% fresh that's the name
of it and it's available starting today
on Netflix who taught you how to play
guitar that's a good question my father
used to strum guitar used to play mala
grania and he used to always sing Moriah
way out west a gonner smoke and fire
that song he used to play it in his room
and I would go down there and he taught
me some chords and then my father told
me actually the guitar I played in the
special is the one that my dad bought me
my father said if you learn don't for no
colloquy Nia I'll buy you that Fender
Stratocaster and I and I practice for
about a year and got it down from
reasonably close and he got me the
stress how many guitars do you I have
she I don't know I I've been given so
many great guitars over the years you
know what another guitar I play you know
the song for Miss will boy that I play
in the yes yes the bond that's a boy I
play a red strat Mark Knopfler gave me
that guitar that's pretty cool the dire
straits Mark Knopfler and any other
famous guitars or people that yeah you
the guitars whoo
Richie Sambora gave me a pretty badass
I stole I stole the guitar from no no
that's it no but I but but Gibson Gibson
loaded me up with guitars when I was on
Saturday Night Live back in the day they
say one of the I think GE Smith or
somebody said to me a they wanted to
play at Gibson and I sang the turkey
song or something I don't even remember
what it was but I then it took all day
up and then throughout my whole SNL
careers gear soon as give me guitars and
stuff and so I little I got my ass I
know probably like 40 great sauce nice
first concert you went to growing up in
New Hampshire my first concert you said
yeah Molly Hatchet Molly yeah yes yes
yeah they were traveling down the road
and they and they stayed with the
Sandman whoa it was at New Hampshire
College oh absolutely
my first one that was my first New
Hampshire my first live band was that
Fanueil Hall in Boston I saw the Four
Tops with my sister Elizabeth thanks
kind of a weird date okay he was that he
was going to be you and she brought me
and then I went and then I and I saw who
else that I see dancer I saw the black
and blue told Black Sabbath and Blue
Oyster Cult
I saw Genesis I saw I saw The Outlaws
green grass and high tides forever yeah
Charlie Daniels Band I saw as a youth
dem went down yeah you sure did yeah
yeah yeah but you Danny what was your
first concert Aerosmith are you kidding
me at hair arena in Dayton
that's insane yeah yeah hey that's a
cool how was it what was it the eros but
that was hitting a soft heart or was
there no no this is when they first
started yeah this was dream on Aerosmith
evil eye
I had an unbelievable concert run where
in the span of about four years I went
to see stones who Zeppelin and boat go I
had friends who had a car and they were
big music fans and so each one like one
was a Bowie fan obviously Zeppelin fan
there was a Stones fan who fan and then
you just you know we'd get tickets and
we go to see him and so it was a pretty
good run you know but I peeked after
that I mean that was that was pretty
good but I got you beat with the folio
of it all because you saw Bowie I jam
with Bowie and tin machine when I was a
young Sandman I was like 23 to 24 and
they came by the show tin machine with
Dave David Bowie lead singer and for
some reason they were that we all hit it
off and I having fun and they and they
were having a jam session that night
they said come on by and play guitar and
I got the jam with them
wait what song did you play I don't even
know we were just chance on everything
because they were just playing any
anything and it happened that I was with
the boys did you talk to Bonnie
sure he was the fat he was so funny and
so cool and relaxed and loved them
welcome and nice a really nice guy he
knew who you were he just knew that I
was a young guy on SNL and he was nice I
stood like he was one of those guys who
showed up with it was nice everybody you
know yeah it was a 50-50 thing if they
were gonna take knowledge the youngsters
or not but though we were so so cool and
funny so funny I yeah like give me the
give me the red star that wasn't nice to
the Sandman Oh in saturnine life you can
tell you could tell menow
was completely turned his back I mean
anything I had to say like acted like I
didn't exist and I still hold a grudge
yes
David Spade you heard
there's no way I would ever say anything
bad about anybody and nobody was that
bad but I'm just saying but we went out
of his way to be nice
did you meet Jagger of course of course
he's good friends with Lauren
so I we all got to meet Jagger McCartney
everybody every everybody we got to meet
that was a I know MA are you gonna
mention my slick guitar leader that I
play during the Chris Farley song how I
put that out there and and bailed a Neil
Young ish kinda bleed that the Farley
song was really well done
touching and I it's it took me by
surprise
because I you know you and Spade you
guys don't talk I mean you talk about
Farley but then you know I always feels
like there's you know unanswered
questions that you guys don't have
answers to so when you did the song I
thought it was a good it was really well
done it was and that really stands out I
loved I said I saying that almost every
show and without a doubt I thought God
bless the most had the biggest reaction
to that because it just loved it
everybody loved it but it's your data
miss you miss them in the glad I got
that forever that sounds like you're
ready to start shooting again on your
movie set so I'll let you be
obliteration yeah I can hear some stuff
there no no you want to know I'm hiding
on the other side of a building and
that's just some people setting up their
restaurant why don't you go in and just
help the people out at the restaurant I
used to work around here at a place
called between the bread you ever hear
that place no I was at when I was when I
was 18 I was I worked I started as a
waiter and then they fired me I became a
busboy and then they fired me became a
dishwasher you can't get demoted further
than a dishwasher can you you know you
know what it was how you I know I was
terrible to work with any time I showed
up to work my whole entire non comedian
career the other person I showed us to
work was like oh and congrats on this
special and hopefully we'll cross paths
we're gonna be when you shoot when do
you rap with a movie we're gonna be in
Los Angeles next month okay good I'll be
out there I got three weeks here more
and then I'm come out there and I'm not
sweet out there and then I was going to
do one five over so we wrote apart we
got we're working on me and our early
here working on so much whoa you buried
the lead so I got a yeah your movie that
I'm gonna be in and you're writing the
script is messy you have no you have no
future in film but in the movie no no no
I like you have you've been in a couple
of films though the love rain or me
punch-drunk love those are films
everything else is pretty much a movie
it's just a movie man you can be in one
of my just abode thank you and good luck
with this special bye
I love you good luck with the World
Series and who's gonna win that you know
I don't know if I did then I knew no no
I think the Red Sox are gonna way but
you that pains you to say it being a
Yankee apologist yes yes but I do I
don't see I don't see you can't stop the
offense and their picture all right now
you're locked okay all right see you but
that's Adam Sandler
it's a Netflix special 100% fresh is the
name of it a lot of those songs he's a
good guitar player and the Farley song
is really well done
it's touchy for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]